[Musique]
c'est comme une faille dans l'espace
temps dans un bazar de moscou se trouve
un beau d'afghanistan tel qu'il existait
il ya 30 ans
bienvenue à sébastopol
sébastopol c'est le nom de ce bâtiment
une ancienne barre d'immeubles
d'habitation transformé en centre
commercial géant nous sommes ici au
coeur de la diaspora afghane toute la
communauté regrouper entre quatre murs
un dédale de couloirs vertigineux jonché
des chocs de quincaillerie et d'objets
souvenirs
ici impossible de filmer sans
autorisation
nous sommes donc escorté de près par
atik raki ni directeur improvisée de la
communication les gens savent qu'ici les
produits sont 10 à 15 % moins cher que
sur le marché le ring ce bâtiment n'est
pas qu'un centre commercial hors d'âge
il est la seule et unique ressource des
afghans de moscou livreur charger petits
commerçants ils sont près de 8000 à se
croiser ici chaque jour une fourmilière
entièrement auto géré les afghans de
sébastopol on leur école leur
boulangerie leurs mosquées
[Musique]
sebastopol c'est une ville dans la ville
dirigée et hiérarchisé comme un
véritable état à sa tête il y a un
président dans son bureau une fois par
semaine ces ambiances conseil des
ministres
on est une diaspora autonome et organisé
en oeuvre à entretenir notre culture
on a tout d'un gouvernement la seule
chose qui manque c'est une armée et une
monnaie
pour comprendre comment fonctionne cette
communauté il faut repartir 33 ans en
arrière en afghanistan en 1979 les chars
russes envahissent le pays sur fond de
guerre froide l'union soviétique ne veut
surtout pas perdre son influence dans la
région
durant dix ans le conflit fait rage face
à la résistance des moudjahidine dix ans
durant lesquels une partie de l'élite
afghane collabore avec les soviétiques
après la défaite de l'armée rouge en
1989 cette élite et chasser du pays nous
la retrouvons ici dans le bureau du
président de la diaspora de moscou tous
dans cette pièce on était généraux
gouverneur de province ou universitaires
là-bas désormais on les appelle les
collabos communiste et personne ne
souhaite les voir revenir
ça fait 15 ans qu'on explique on n'est
pas des communismes
nous n'avons jamais eu ces idées là
nous sommes juste des patriotes
14-18 tous ces hommes ici ne peuvent pas
servir l'afghanistan c'est dommage c'est
un vrai gâchis et c'est vraiment rageant
en exil forcé ces anciens hauts
responsables ont recréé leur petit
afghanistan ils ont dû faire avec ce que
la russie leur offrait c'est à dire pas
grand chose mis à part la liberté de
s'autogérer ils ont trouvé une niche le
business des babioles made in china
c'est ainsi que l'ancien intelligentsia
afghane s'est reconverti dans la
quincaillerie ou tinto
je suis triste moi j'étais professeur
j'étais fier d'enseigner aux jeunes
générations
en afghanistan il ya 150 ingénieurs que
j'ai formés qui travaillent encore là
bas c'est pas une question de salaire
gaz et nefta mr bling mais j'aurais
voulu continuer à servir mon pays j'ai
progressé dans la boutique d'à côté le
commerçant n'est autre qu'un ancien
présentateur de la télévision d'état
afghane pour lui la russie est un refuge
stocker l'eau
quand on nous demande ce que
représentent les russes pour nous nous
répond c'est comme un grand oncle
on est venu habiter sous le même toit
que notre oncle
pour nous c'est comme une deuxième
patrie
tous ces commerçants décrivent la russie
comme le meilleur des mondes pourtant le
pays n'est pas franchement réputé
clément avec ces immigrés
[Musique]
à six russie de distance sur la même
chose pour nous
on est tout à fait d'accord avec la
politique de poutine en matière
d'émigration
ici on est libre et indépendant on fait
ce qu'on veut il ya
un discours de connivence qui a de quoi
surprendre
la raison ne surtout pas froisser des
autorités russes qui tolère le business
quelque peu opaque de sébastopol la
journée s'étire et atic nous balade dans
un univers de farces et attrapes
depuis que nous sommes ici un truc
cloche nous n'avons toujours pas vu
l'ombre d'une femme afghane à sébastopol
pour les trouver il faut en fait grimper
au dernier étage du bâtiment car la
direction de la diaspora lors interdit
de travailler dans les boutiques
couvé dabbagh wéry et la présidente de
la section des femmes à kaboul elle
était députée et grande militante de la
cause féminine
menacé par les talibans elle a fui il ya
deux ans
la plupart de ces femmes sont à moscou
depuis 15 ans mais elle ne parle
toujours pas la langue
un repli communautaire auquel voudrait
mettre fin coup veda qui a créé ces
cours lorsqu'elle est arrivée
entre femmes et en l'absence des chefs
la parole se libère ici l'accueil des
immigrés dans la société russe est
perçue de façon radicalement différente
à celle des hommes
les mois de mars et la
relation
non
protégée d'une vie au style mais quand
on est loin de l'activité des hommes
pour ces femmes les murs de la
communauté sont un refuge bien précaire
[Musique]
un
constat amer pour couver d'aba où eric
ce soir nous l'a raccompagné à la maison
son fils et sa fille l'y attendent tous
trois ont fui kaboul dans la
précipitation là-bas son statut de
député et son engagement auprès des
femmes n'était pas du goût des talibans
qui gangrène le pays
[Musique]
nathalie diaz à notre sarko
info liette canadian coal co na ou de
monique michat d'un fournisseur à
l'habitude lamielle pour le boss relève
la tête
migros n'a qu'un
mot ni moche à la mairie tard type
macadam téléphonie à retordre aux
méthodes
pour l'aider à payer le loyer son fils
de 17 ans travaillent sept jours sur
sept à décharger des camions pourtant
c'est un petit génie il parle sept
langues d'asie centrale était promis à
de grandes études de médecine depuis
deux ans il n'a pris que deux jours de
vacances
tazi mission que m'a surtout
quel avenir alors pour la jeunesse
afghane de moscou si ce n'est sébastopol
le lendemain matin retour dans les
couloirs du grand bazar à les tâches des
femmes il y à aussi leurs enfants à qui
elles apprennent à parler afghans
[Musique]
la plupart de ces bambins sont nés à
moscou vont à l'école à moscou mais ils
savent déjà que la russie n'est pas leur
patrie
l'afghan et notre langue on doit le
comprendre le lire et l'écrire
quand on rentrera à kaboul si on parle
mal on nous dira qu'on n'est pas dans
mes ressources
le retour au pays une idée fixe pour
cette communauté de bani il est vrai que
vu de derrière les persiennes de
sébastopol la russie paraît si loin
[Musique]